The voicemail number for the show is two one
nine two David p.
Here's another song submitted to the David
Pakman show.
Take a listen to this one.
Hello David.
Well, Hello David.
It's so nice to have you back on your youth
to show your look.
Can Saw David.
I can uh, Dave [inaudible] yours still clo
and yours still go and your still [inaudible]
strong.
Yes.
Very good.
Thank you.
I don't know if that is a supposed to be made
also into a dubstep EDM remix, but at this
point the questions, uh, around whether these
are satirical songs or nod are only growing
and uh, thank you for the submission.
I appreciate it.
Is this me?
Is this the best singer from our audience
so far that has submitted a song?
That is my question to you.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
450,000 people applied for Andrew Yang's thousand
dollar a month offer that he announced at
the presidential debate last week.
We will also talk more about Donald Trump
looking to turn New Mexico red and Arizona's
supreme court has green-lit discrimination
against, against same sex weddings.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, I implore you
to join me there by becoming a member@joinpacman.com
or a patron at patrion.com/david package.
Gotcha.
[inaudible]
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.